brush.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Welcome to the October 8, 2025
full board meeting of Manhattan
Community Board 6. My name is Sandy McKe
and I am the chair of CB6. This meeting
is called to order at 7:02 p.m. Tonight
we are joined by First Vice Chair John
Keller, Secretary Justin Goldberg,
District Manager Jesus Perez, Assistant
District Manager Brendan Berth, and
community coordinator Brian Laferty.
aren't at the door. I think playing uh
New York State law requires all
community board members who are not able
to attend the meeting in person to have
their cameras on and their first and
last name displayed from the time the
meeting is called to order until the
time the meeting is adjourned. We
observe we observe the following ground
rules. Do not speak until granted the
floor. Please raise your hand and wait
for me to recognize you. We have
microphones at the front. Um, two
microphones today and we'd like you to
come to those to speak, please. Um, it
is important that only one person speaks
at a time so that members of the public
watching at home can understand what is
being said. Um,
you will come to the microphone once
you're recognized. The chat function
should not be used for CB6 business or
questions about agenda topics. Members
of the public, if you wish to give
remarks during the public session and
have not already registered by filling
out a form, you can register to speak um
in the public session on Zoom by using
the Q&A feature and posting your name,
your affiliation, and what topic you
wish to speak about. or if you are here
in person and want to speak in the
public session, you need to fill out our
public speaker form which is near the
sign-in sheets um for the for the CB6
newsletter and this needs to be done by
7:15.
The agenda for tonight's meeting was
distributed ahead of time by the board
office was posted online and appears on
the screen before you.
If there is no objection,
we will adopt the agenda as stated. If
you object to adopting the agenda, you
may raise your hand.
Seeing no excuse me, seeing no
objections, the agenda for tonight's
meeting is adopted.
Justin will now take attendance by roll
call.
>> We'll now take attendance by roll call.
Board members, when your name is called,
please say present.
>> Ready.
>> Tanya Aras,
>> present.
>> Kyle Tide.
>> Neil Barklay,
>> present.
Marty Barrett,
>> Elby Barroso,
>> present.
>> Daniel Bernstein,
>> Liz Burr,
>> present.
>> Jim Collins
>> here.
>> Steuart Desert
>> Beatatric Disman.
>> Is she on?
>> Um, she's having issues with the Zoom
link.
>> Go back to her then.
>> Am I a Don?
Robert Fairfan
Bar Freriedman
>> present.
>> Jason Brmitz,
>> Eric Goldberg,
>> Justin Goldberg,
>> Gloria Hage,
>> Rivia Hickball,
>> present.
>> Ha. Judge,
Ra,
>> she's not here.
John Keller,
>> present.
>> Kate Kennedy,
>> Katie Landa,
>> present.
>> Sandra Ltoff,
>> Anton Molner,
>> not here.
>> Not here.
>> Sandra McKe,
>> present.
>> Alec Militic,
>> Richard Mintz,
>> present.
>> Kevin O'Keefe,
>> Rashma Patel,
>> present.
Steven Perez,
Will Perry,
Omeishi,
>> Miriam Roth,
>> Michael Anroe,
>> absent.
>> Lauren Shy,
>> present.
>> Anne Celigman
>> here.
>> Sandra Sherrod.
>> Mubin Sadiki. Letty
Simon.
>> She should be excused.
I sent the letter in.
>> She's excused.
>> Present.
>> Gabriel Turtzo
>> present.
>> Cad Valero
>> James
>> present.
>> Jerry Weinstein
>> Sarah Whittington
>> present.
>> David Woods
and Sha Zhao.
>> All right, with 35 members duly present,
we do have
>> our elected officials sent in their
reports ahead of time and they are
compiled on the CB6 website. The link to
the reports was sent out ahead of time
as well and for your convenience can be
found in the chat on Zoom or by going to
our websites page for full board
meetings. I will call on each of the
elected officials who have RSVP so that
they can take questions from CB6 members
and the public about their presubmitted
reports. Each elected official will be
able to field questions. If there are no
questions, we will move to the next
official on our list. Um, if an elected
official has a time-sensitive matter to
report on that didn't make it into their
presubmitted l report, they will have
three minutes to do so.
Um,
we do expect our congressman to join us
this evening. Um, maybe later. Um, so
we'll move on to Joanna Sanchez who's
number one tonight.
>> Okay, great. Um Wendy Brennan from
Senator Krueger's office.
>> Hi, I just want to report on two quick
things. We have an upcoming virtual
event next week on October 14th from 2
to 3:30. It's on the federal impact to
for older adults to cuts in Medicare and
Medicaid. The link is in my report. And
we do have a live event on October 28th,
an older adult resource fair. It's from
11:30 to 2:30 at Lennox Hill
Neighborhood House and the information
is also in the newsletter. Thank you and
good to see all of you.
>> Do we have any questions? Ann, if you
could please go to the microphone.
>> Yeah. Hi, I just want to say I went to
>> Hi. I just want to say I I attended the
uh webinar yesterday on Medicare and it
was great. So um thank you very much for
that and
for those of us here who are eligible
like this is a great resource and you
should be aware
>> and you can call the office we can send
you a link if you didn't register. It is
the guy from the department of uh for
the aging is terrific.
Great. Okay.
Any other questions? All right. Thank
you very much. Um, next we have Payton
Schultice from Senator Gonzalez's
office.
>> Hi. I just have one quick thing I wanted
to add to the report. I'm sure you're
all aware. Last month the CAC voted down
the proposed casino at Freedom Plaza.
The senator feels similarly. the senator
is very happy with this outcome. She,
you know, is very aware of the
immense community
u opposition to this proposal is very
happy that the CAC made this decision.
Also, you know, thank you Sandy for
serving on the CAC
>> and and Rushma as well.
Thank you
and appreciate uh all of the board's
work around this issue as well. Uh happy
to take any questions.
>> Do we have any questions for the
senator's office? Great. Thank you very
much.
>> Thank you.
>> Um we have Christian Williams from the
mayor's office.
>> Hi Wendy. I'm so sorry. It should say uh
Jasper Diaz. Um, first of all, I want to
thank you so much for having me. Um, I'm
the new Manhattan B director, uh, the
mayor's community affairs unit. Uh,
Robin Forest, center of regards, and
she's now with first deputy mayor Randy
Mastro's office. Um, some of you may not
know me. I did put my contact
information in the chat. If you ever
need any assistance uh, for the city
regarding any issues, have any
questions, please feel free to reach out
to me and I will be sure to uh, submit a
report uh, through the system um, for
the next meeting.
Okay. Do we have any questions for the
mayor's office?
All right. Thank you. Thanks very much.
>> Thanks so much.
>> Uh, next we have Patrick Hill from
Council Member P's office.
>> Good evening everyone. Uh, thank you for
having me virtually. Um, I don't have
anything to add uh to our report. Just
want to highlight that we have a free
bike helmet fitting uh event happening
on October 18th uh in Stytown from 11 to
2:30 p.m. 11 a.m. to 2:30 p.m. It'll be
at playground 9. Uh and we have info
that we can send over to the uh to the
community board staff as well in case
they want to share it with folks.
>> Do we have any any questions for um for
Keith P's office?
>> Great. Okay. Thanks very much. Thank
you. Um,
>> next we have Curtis Young from the
Public Advocates Office.
>> Curtis has his hand raised.
Um,
maybe having I Curtis, you're having uh
issues with the Zoom.
We can
can
>> Curtis, you may speak.
Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Yes, we can. Thank you.
>> Okay, perfect. Thank you. So, oh, you
can hear me. Okay, but you can't see me.
Let's see if I can start my video. His
video is not permitted.
>> We We had We We tried to promote you,
but you kept declining. So, unless you
unless you accept, we can't see your
video. So,
>> Oh, okay. Well, if you want to try
again, I can try, but I can also just
wing it. Um,
>> no problem.
>> Okay. Well, thank you all. Um, once
again, it's great to be here with CB6.
Just a few updates. Some apologies for
not submitting the report in advance.
I'm trying to get better at that in
advance. I will do my best for November.
Um but I just wanted to share that um
this month the governor extended an
executive order that allows pharmacists
to continue administering CO 19 vaccines
providing access to all New Yorkers who
wish to be vaccinated. Um just
information for the city, the executive
order will be placed uh in place for
another 30 days and is a part of
Governor Hoku's first um against um
first fight against Washington's new CO
rules. So, that's very good news that we
can share with all New Yorkers. Um,
also, New Yorkers can still sign up for
their updated COVID 19 vaccination by
visiting nyc.gov/co
express. Um, as far as legislative
updates, recently the public advocate
spoke at a hearing of the committee on
mental health, disabilities, and
addiction at city hall regarding the
need for a robust 988 infrastructure,
calling for improvements and investments
that integrate with be heard and other
intervention programs. Um, he believes
that the city must invest in crisis
response hotline and expand its response
services to New Yorkers. Um, also
currently at, as many of you have seen
in the newspaper, currently at 26
Federal Plaza, ICE has been detaining
immigrants in inhumane, abusive
conditions and attacking individuals,
including journalists inside the
building. As you saw, elected officials
were also arrested recently. And um,
last month, the US court granted an
injunction that would improve conditions
for people detained by ICE at 26 Federal
Plaza. Um, and as you know, ne the next
day after that injunction, the public
advocate and others were arrested there.
So, the fight continues. Um, we have a
few upcoming events. You can follow them
by visiting our event page and also sign
up for our newsletter and other
information there. I'm happy to take any
questions.
>> Do we have any questions for the public
advocate?
No, we don't this evening. Thank you
very much.
>> Thank you.
>> Um, Jerry Nadler, our congressman has
joined us. Please
welcome to C6.
Thank you very much. Thank you very
much. Um,
as you know, they don't mean to shut
down now. Uh, the Republicans, well, let
me tell you what's at stake first.
a trillion dollars in healthcare funds,
a trillion dollars for Medicaid, leaving
16 million people uninsured.
Hospitals, community health centers
closing. And remember, we live in New
York City. The hospital closes, we go to
different hospital in Manhattan. If
you're in a rural area and hospital 5
miles away closes, you may have to go 75
miles. and on the way there you could
die because it's an if it's an emergency
uh situation. Now the Republicans don't
want to extend the Affordable Care Act
tax credit and this means that tax that
the cost would go up by 115%.
So, a 60-year-old
uh couple making $80,000
would have a medical a a a an insurance
cost increase of $17,000
on an $8,000
couple's income. Now, this is
ridiculous. Now, the Republicans say,
"Well,
you know, we'll work that out.
vote to continue those with the
continuing resolution, reopen the
government will work that out except
that the enrollment period starts
November 1st and people are already
getting their notices which include
these huge increases.
In addition to which
um
the Republicans say, "Well, pass a clean
CR." And we'll talk about it later.
Besides the objection I just said, we
passed the clean CR back in March.
And Chuck Schub got a lot of criticism
for that, but we passed the clean CR in
March. It expired last week, September
30th.
The president wouldn't negotiate until
September 30th. And there's no way
you're going to reach a five quarter
deal. By a five quarter deal, I mean the
president, the majority minority
leaders, the Senate, the speaker, and
minority of the House. And that's what
you have to do. There's no way you're
going to do that in less than one day.
So this is going on. Propose are trying
to say, well, you know, we'll take care
of it. No, they won't take care of it.
We tried that once and you know there's
an old saying fool me once shame on you
fool me twice shame on me we've been
through that now the government shutdown
aside
they are administration
is taking it out trying to uh hurt blue
space so they have cancelled they say on
grounds of deer
d diversity, equity, inclusion, which
they're opposing. They have cancelled
the Second Avenue subway extension and
the um
Gateway tunnel project. I take this
personally because I did a lot of work
to get funding for those. I'm on the
transportation committee,
but that's $18 billion.
It's $300,000
commuters. And if one of those tunnels
were to fail,
the economic impact would spread
throughout the country, starting with
the Northeast, would spread throughout
the country. Now, why are they doing
this? They say it's DEI. That's not the
real reason. They're cancelling projects
all over the place in blue states only.
So, we're dealing with people who are
who behave dishonorably,
and we have to stand our ground. There's
no way around it and u that's all I can
say. Are there any questions?
>> Um Tanya would like to go first the
microphone over here.
>> And thank you enough for all that you do
and thank you for being here. How does
this end?
>> I don't know. Nobody knows how this
ends.
and snake.
>> Snake, but no one knows how it ends.
>> Dave,
>> thank you. In your opinion, is this a
tactic or the end game for them? They
trying to kill the projects.
>> I think they're trying to kill some of
the projects. I don't know that they're
trying to kill all of them. But it's
unknowable. I
It's just hard to believe they want to
kill all the projects that they're
threatening. It would really uh hurt the
country in so many ways, but they do
>> Jerry.
>> Thank you so much. Um did you and your
staff have a chance to read the Guardian
Opus
Monigan today about a blue state
compact? It's generating a fair amount
of discussion. No, I I haven't seen it.
>> Um, just in grief is what what it sounds
like
massing and and everything from
theatricality to having an oppositional
framework about what to do for this
moment.
>> Well,
sounds like a good idea. I have to look
into it more. Sounds like a good idea. I
mean, I hate to see the country uh split
into two halves. We went through that in
1861.
>> Um B, you have a question. Please go
ahead.
>> I do. Yes. Uh good evening, Congressman.
I do have a question of two issues that
have come up. One is the fact of firing
some of the non-essential employees that
are being threatened. And second is the
threat not to uphold the law that
provides the back pay for those that
would, you know, working and deemed
non-essential. Any comments or thoughts
about those issues?
>> People who are deemed essential by the
president, by air traffic controllers
have to work and will get paid later.
people deemed non- essential
stay home and get paid later. And the
president's threat to deny some of the
people pay is simply illegal. There's a
law, I forget the title of the law, uh
that says that the people must get paid,
all of them. This law was signed into
law
by President Trump in his first term.
Do we have any other questions for the
congressman?
>> Well, in that case, thank you very much.
>> Well, thank you so much for coming.
>> Um, following our congressman, we now
have um Harvey Epstein,
our assembly member.
And and
Jim, sorry if you don't mind.
>> You know, really, we should just give
the congress member. I mean, Congressman
Nadler for decades has served our city
and really he deserves a round of
applause.
Thank you for everything you do in
Washington, you've done in Albany, and
what you've done for our city. Um, your
leadership has been amazing. Uh, so I
wanted to come this month because I know
the casino was a big issue that we've
been talking a lot. Um, I want to thank
my rent who happens to be sitting in the
back. Thank you for all the work.
There was a lot of work, but I know you
did what you could to represent our
community well and I think the outcome
really rose to the values of what this
community needed and really spoke for
today. First, thank you for all your
work.
You know, we are, as the congress member
said, in really troubling times. Let's
be honest about that.
>> We are likely to see
military, national guard, troops on our
streets and we just need to be prepared
for that. That is, it feels like an
eventuality.
So, I think we need to be thoughtful
about what we do over the next couple
months. We need to be caring about our
neighbors and our friends and our loved
ones. And we need to stick together to
know that people of goodwill are going
to do the best they can during difficult
times. And think about this country and
its history. Even over the last hundred
years, we've and you know, people have
lived through really difficult times
before us. They got up every day. They
did what they could to make the world a
little less bad. And it's our
responsibility in these difficult times
to do the same thing. We have to be
optimistic that the world's going to be
a bit better place at some point. I'm
just not sure in the next 3 years we'll
see it. But it doesn't mean we can't
keep fighting and standing up for what
we believe in.
The last thing I'll say is um well it's
October of 2025.
This may be my last meeting as an asama
member representing this community. I
just wanted to thank you for your
partnership, your friendship, your work,
your commitment to this community. Uh it
really takes all of us. But the people
know I've said that I served on my
community board for 14 years, chair of
lots of communities, including chair of
the board. None of that is easy.
Takes someone who cares deeply about
their neighborhood to give them that
right. So, I just want to know thank you
all and thank you for your work. And if
the chair uh says there's any questions,
I'm happy to answer them. But you know,
I just wanted to wish you a happy new
year and thank you for for doing your
work
>> and thank you.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> We have any questions for the
assemblyman.
>> All right. Well, thank you everyone.
Have a good evening.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Next we have Julie Roland from Assembly
Member Bores's office.
>> She's here. Oh, here. Oh, okay. Hi.
>> I think hello everyone. Uh, first things
first, I'm Julie Roland. I'm the new
district director.
I'm the new district director for
Assembly Member Morris. So, maybe you've
seen Sophia Miller, some other staff
members. I'm going to be
acting up.
>> I'm going to be getting acclimated, but
uh today's my third day, so please be
nice. I would love to meet you all and
hope to be in person at these meetings
as much as possible. So, please grab me,
talk to me. Um, this is my third day in
the job and my third day in New York.
So, really um like I want to hear all
about I I've been like my mom is from
New York, my sister lives in New York. I
finally made it home after the military,
but I would love to get to know this
community through your eyes. So, please
talk to me, tell me your experiences.
Um, really excited about that. But now,
I'm going to get to the announcements.
One is assembly member Boris and his
wife have happily given birth to a new
baby boy Charlie August 16th. Everyone
is healthy. They're taking some time
obviously, but thank you all for your
well wishes there. Um and then wanted to
give an update on the telemarketing
bill. So our office passed a bipartisan
legislation that nearly doubled the max
fine for the do not call list
violations. Uh that was in 2023. So, we
put together a report to see how that's
been doing, how how people have been
responding to the new enforcements, and
we found that in the decade before the
law, there were two fines that exceeded
100,000, but since it took effect, we've
already had 10. So, what that means is
sending a really clear message that we
will enforce those fines if you violate
the do not call. So, making sure you
guys don't get bothered and if you do
that there's the proper consequences.
Um, want to let you know we have a shred
truck tomorrow morning. We'll be hosting
that from our district office. That's at
40th in Lex, but 353 Lexington. That's
from 9 till noon. If you guys shrug,
please come by if you just want to hang
out. Okay. Um, and then also we are
offering notary services Monday through
Thursday from 10il 2. That's also at
district office. Um, other than that,
we've got uh all this should probably be
on the form that we sent and I know
we'll be um answering some more
legislative questions on the 23rd
meeting or the whatever that meeting is.
So, anyway, if you have any questions
for me now, I'll stick around. Yes.
>> Notary services free or not?
>> Really? They're afraid.
>> You can range wildly.
>> Uh, no. We've got someone on our staff
who went through the program. Yeah.
Please, please come by.
>> Okay.
>> Anyone else?
>> Any other questions?
Great. Thank you so much. Look forward
to working with you.
>> Great. Thank you for coming.
>> So,
next we have Spencer from Council
District 2. Oh, you're here. Hi.
>> Probably this one.
>> Uh, good evening everyone. Uh, I have
just a couple quick announcements. Uh, I
just want to say that our the the New
York City Council District 2 office is
still open even though the former
council member has departed. We still
have staff in the office every day of
the week from 10:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
Uh, we're checking all the emails, the
phones. So, definitely continue to reach
out if you need assistance with anything
city or council related. Uh, I also
wanted to flag that there are some
upcoming ballot proposals that will
appear on the ballot this November. uh
they were drafted by the mayor's charter
vision commission and none of them
relate to land use and housing. Um it
would take a long time to go into detail
about the potential impacts of all these
proposals, but I brought some palm
cards. I implore everyone to scan the QR
code, the website, go through them. If
you ever have any questions, feel free
to reach out to our office. Uh and yeah,
happy to answer any questions.
your microphone.
>> You you may want to announce that on the
15th there's going to be also a sort of
um town hall regarding those
those questions.
>> Yes, there's also a charter revision
commission town halls coming up. Um
unfortunately our office can't release
uh communications right now. We're we're
kind of limited in what communications
we can release. So please check out the
pawn cards, check out the website. The
website is what's on my ballot.nyc IC
that has information on all the
>> Thank you.
>> Any any other questions? No, we're good.
Okay. Thanks very much.
>> Okay.
All right. Has anyone signed up to
speak?
>> They they have
>> public session.
>> They have. Um, we have four people
signed up. Uh, first one, Rebecca Carter
from the New York County Defender
Services who would like to provide
information on a know your rights
training that her organization offers.
Miss Carter, are you here?
I do not see you online.
Going once, going twice in the room. All
right, then we'll move on. Um Stephanie
Hill, a parent um of a student at the UN
International School uh who wishes to
speak about issues uh with homeless
individuals near the school. Miss Hill,
are you here?
I do not see her
in the room.
All right.
Next on the I do not see her online
either, but next on the list is
Nichollet Ramirez, a resident of
Manhattan Community District 6, who
wishes to speak about homelessness near
East 23rd Street and the FDR Drive as
well as the intersection there. Um,
Ms. Ramirez, you have three minutes to
give your remarks. You may begin your
remarks now. Hi, I think I'm speaking
also for the parent of Ununice. I'm also
a parent of Ununice. So, it's about the
traffic situation and the homelessness
situation. I'll just read what I
prepared. I hope it's 3 minutes. But
basically, we need people to take
responsibility for the homeless
situation. Right now, it's cleared. This
past week, somebody took the initiative.
I think we've been in touch with Ben
Jacobs uh with Keith P's office. I think
the school as well as community members
like myself. But basically, we want
someone to regularly keep an eye out for
people who are not just homeless, but
who also need mental health um care. U
because we've had incidents at the
school uh just a week or two ago, a
child was hit in the head with a bottle
by a homeless person. Whether they're
mentally disturbed or not, we don't
know. Also, we need either traffic signs
because on the intersection of 23rd and
the FDR, there's the bike path by the
gas station and there's no sign there
for the bikers to slow down. So, the
people have the cross sign, but the
bikers just keep going. It's also the
same with the cars turning the corner
there. There's a blind spot, so the
people on the north side of 23rd
crossing FDR have the cross sign, but
the cars coming around have no idea that
the people are crossing. Um, I spoke to
the person at UNUNICE who's in charge of
security. He said if he had to keep
track of all the bike, pedestrian, car
incidents, he would have a non-stop job
247. So, we need some attention on that
area for the homeless, for the mental
health, and for the traffic situation. I
think that's it.
>> Thank you for your remarks.
>> Um,
Jason wants to respond. Jason is the
chair of our transportation committee.
Jason from one
in terms about um pedestrian safety uh
and bike safety on that intersection
23rd and FDR. Uh we're aware uh of the
situation there. We've been uh
advocating with the DFT to to make some
changes and improvements. Uh they've
unfortunately been resistant to making
any immediate changes given the
construction that's going on um in that
area under the um ESCR parallel
conveyance project. Uh we'll continue to
advocate with them to um make those
changes as projects I believe ramping
up. Uh and we have a meeting tomorrow
with the new burough commissioner where
uh intend to bring this up uh again to
to continue to advocate changes there.
Uh so uh we're we're aware of of the
situation with traffic there and uh also
trying to to make some improvements.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Next on the list is Jorge
Vargas, a resident of this district who
wish to wishes to speak to the board
about traffic safety and homeless
encampments. Mr. Vargas, you have three
minutes to make your remarks. You may
begin now.
>> Thank you. Yes, my name is Far Vargas
and I came here in 1977 at the age of
seven and I've lived in Simson Town on
20th Street and I remember my first day
of school crossing 23rd Street in FDR,
the one we're talking about just
previously and cars would zoom past 23rd
Street off cars come down FDR North and
would cheat and light the race down
through FDR side streets. Those offcar
ramps in the south would also beat the
light and speed across. I went to
Ununice for many years and I avoided the
cars and I saw various accidents
personally and heard of others. 48 years
later, my six-year-old daughter and I
make the same journey home to United
Nations schools every day. And as I
cross the street and see hundreds of
childrens and parents cross that street,
I see that this dangerous intersection
is even more dangerous. And now,
according to New York City data, there's
a thousand cars passing there just
during 8 and 9:00 a.m. I come here to
ask for your help to really push this
through because I want to avoid future
accidents and I hope I never or anyone
else have to come back to report on the
death of a young child or a parent. So,
simple solutions can really help us. I
heard that you guys are talking for the
construction. I have not seen
construction and in fact, there was a
cutting ribbon ceremony probably a
couple weeks ago. So hopefully that's
done, but this is a very dangerous
intersection and I believe that there's
many simple solutions we can put in
place like you know crosswalk signs,
bumps in the road, even when the police
are there, cars still avoid and
basically pass through intersections. So
I do look upon the the various boards
here members to please do something.
I've know that on January 8th, Matt
McCllo came here as a resident of CB6 as
well to present the case, the same case
for Ununice as well as the British
International School. And we need to do
something very quickly before something
bad happens. Thank you.
>> Thank you for your remarks, Mr. Vargas.
That concludes the speakers list for
tonight.
>> Thank you.
Um, the minutes from the September,
excuse me, the minutes from the
September 10th full board meeting were
distributed to board members ahead of
time by the board office. If there is no
objection, we will adopt the minutes as
drafted. Board members, if you object to
adopting the minutes, you may raise your
hand. Seeing no objections,
the minutes from the September 10th full
board meeting are adopted. They will
soon be available on the CB6 website.
Um, chair's report. So, uh, John and I
have reached out to our fellow Manhattan
community boards regarding the charter
charter revision commission's proposals
that will appear in November's ballot.
And as we heard from our district 2
office,
um, four of our other community boards
have expressed interested in co-hosting
a forum to help ensure that the public
is well informed of the proposals. Um,
as we proceed, all boards understand
that we must not act in a way that
attempts to influence the outcome of the
election. That's against the law. We're
not allowed to do that. But we do feel
that um a public forum sponsored by CB6
and other community boards will provide
a full and fair opportunity for all
concerned to be informed on the
importance of these ballot measures. Um,
so yes, it's ballot measure 2, three,
and four. It's complicated. It's um it
really needs a very, you know,
thoughtful review and we're hoping to do
that before election day. So, um if you
can, this may be the first one that we
had, but we may have others.
Um we had a presentation on the upgrades
to the 34th Street parking area last
night and the improvements that the
parks department is making to the space.
It's called an interim open space uh
with the understanding that the area
needs to be considered holistically as
part of the greenway system, but they
are installing some improvements to the
34th Street area. Um and they're doing
it very quickly. This is sort of a
record-breaking installation. So, um
it's great. Um the board office is
sending out a notice from the
independent budget office um which is a
nonpartisan city agency that impro
improves budget transparency through
analyzing budget and policy um data. Uh
they'll be hosting a webinar on October
20th at 12. I recommend attending. They
gave a presentation at Burough Board
which was really wellreceived, very
informative. Um, and the burough
president also has leadership training
sessions that are extremely helpful
coming up. I think everybody received
the notice regarding that their
sessions.
Okay, good. I see a few nods. It went
right over, right? Um, and um, I
understand that the history of some of
our long-term uh, issues that the board
has been dealing with may be difficult
to access. Uh, so it's helpful to go
back to past meetings. Zoom is our
friend in this case. I know you're all
looking for something to do late at
night, go back and look at those past
meetings. Um, and also take a look at
the resolutions that have been passed
spec and if you have a very specific
issue that you would like to know
something about, the air table allows
you to search very well. And I think we
can search our minutes as well using
>> we have a minutes database on our
homepage. So you there you can find
minutes for all the meetings assuming
they were submitted uh and uh links to
the uh video agenda presentations and
then we of course have the reso tracker
which hopefully everyone is very
familiar with.
So, and I know there I mean last last
meeting we heard about why isn't our
east side waterfront as nice as the west
side. And if you go back, you'll see
that we've been working on this for a
long time. And so, if there's a specific
issue, you can kind of check out what
our advocacy has been and maybe have
some ideas for what else we can do. So,
um
>> All right. And if you do have a very
specific issue, you can always ask the
chair of the committee or or speak to me
about any history that we have. Okay.
And our district manager, who I
neglected to ask last month if he had a
report, um said he's going to wave, but
I'll let him say that himself.
>> Mercifully, I will wave.
>> Okay. And now our treasurer B. Dishman
will give Disman will give her report.
So mine will be short also in the
interest of time. So according to the
crystal report received for September in
October CB6 is budgeted $627,663
for the fiscal year. However, this
includes $145,91
for street fairs and the street fair
money actually went up this month
because we were paid in September $5590.
We've already encumbered or liquidated
about $259,220
and it leaves us unencumbered money of
$368,442.
I just want to alert everyone we it's
very very tight budget last year. As a
matter of fact, we had dip into street
bear money and we don't anticipate that
this year will be any different. It is
extremely tight. So, we have to be
extremely careful in what we're doing.
But the budget doesn't give us a lot of
leeway. Sandy, if anyone has any
questions,
>> do any questions for our treasurer?
>> Jason,
>> sorry, just out of curiosity. Uh, mostly
what is it? What is the implication of
dipping into the street fair money and
why do we not want to do that? Well, we
have a resolution from the executive
committee that street fair money can be
used for the benefit of the community
board or interest within the community
board setting. We have been saving the
money from the street fair because of
the budgets and the tightening of the
budgets and the desire to have the
staffing that we have. But we had no
choice but dipping in because of the uh
different salaries and what we have as
staffing. So we have the right by
executive committee resolution, but we
need to remember once that money is gone
and the budget is tight, we have no
leeway.
>> Okay, any other questions?
All right, thank you. Um, we've now
arrived we've now arrived at our
committee reports and resolutions.
Members of the public, please note that
during this section of the meeting, we
only recognize questions from members of
the board. The CB6 staff emailed the
digital ballot to all members. Please
click on the link in your email that the
office sent to open the ballot. Select
your name from the drop-own list and
vote on each resolution when they are
presented. Do not hit submit until later
in the meeting after the final
resolution has been presented and
discussed. After you have indicated all
your votes on your ballot, you can
submit it. You will not be able to
submit the ballot unless you vote on
every resolution. If you plan on
abstaining, select abstain and note that
this will count as a negative vote in
the final count. Final vote counts will
be announced after the second roll call.
If any po part of our voting procedure
is unclear, please raise your hand and
we will address your question. All
right, so first up we have Steve Perez,
chair of budget and governmental
affairs.
>> Thank you Sandy. Um, good evening
everyone. So we have a resolution from
our committee which is presenting our
capital and expense budget requests for
fiscal year 2027.
Every committee should be familiar with
requests they submitted. Um, I do want
to point out that this year with the
approval of the executive committee, we
went through an indepth review of all
the requests and went through a process
to say that if the requests that were
very old and outdated or were not
specific enough, we removed them. Um,
that was, you know, done in the
committee meeting. So, happy to answer
any questions.
Marty could
>> be noted that over the years some things
take 20 years to get.
So it's quite possible that we're
eliminating things that we we've been
working on forever.
>> Marty, did you have anything specific
you wanted to address? No. Okay.
>> Just
>> Okay.
>> It is what it is.
>> All right. Thank you. Um, Alec,
>> I'd like to make a motion to um
reinclude affordable housing funding as
part of our capital funding request. Um,
I watched the YouTube recording and I
agree with a lot of the points that the
committee made. Um, and I I think that
this issue is just too important for us
to not include as a budget request this
year. we've included as budget requests
in years past. Um, and this city has
always responded saying that they
support this. Um, and I think that this
is something that we should um, include
going forward.
>> So that's
>> second. So um, I think we have the text
up for what the proposal was for
including affordable housing.
Um, if you'd like to take a minute to
read that. Can everybody see it?
>> No. Right. Um,
>> I can maybe just summarize the way that
we read it as committee. Um, it's a very
good need statement of the need for
affordable housing, but it's not really
a budget request. And that's what
mystified us about why we're submitting
a need state and for we're asking for a
capital allocation from HPD.
And I don't see how HBD can respond to
this in any way that they've ever
responded, which is we support it and we
will try to accommodate within our
resources. So if that's the kind of
response we want, happy to submit it
again, but I'm not sure what the the
goal is of submitting a meeting
statement as a budget request when it's
not the budget request.
uh cat
>> not to get into the weeds um but I'm
just and I do not with all due respect
watch the committee meeting but um
recognizing that there were some
proposals from health and environment a
couple others that were from this I
totally understand but in your opinion
does the budget and governing committee
have like a template or a proposal of
how to
structure
a budget request that isn't like as you
said a need statement that would be
under strong consideration under the
dynamics deficit.
>> So we there was some offline discussions
that happened over the summer with
between me and the committee chairs
where I was asking questions and giving
them ideas about how to make their um
budget requests more specific. some of
um I mean obviously some issues are so
difficult or perhaps you know the
committees didn't meet over the summer
so it was not possible to necessarily
come up with a great solution for this
meeting but now we can't we don't have
any more time to sort of and I know that
the housing committee is looking at
getting all the specific reports and
data they need to be able to structure
their but we just aren't there yet so I
mean every committee has different
um that it's hard to say there's one
formula for different committees who
will have very different kinds of
robots, but there was a dialogue over
the summer about suggestions and ways to
the silver housing specifically. It was
who was the housing for,
what is affordable housing and and where
I mean that would be a budget. Uh,
Marty,
>> now that we've decided that after 20
years of that pit beard, we're weren't
going to do anything with it by h by
getting rid of the uh need in the
community for affordable housing. We're
telling our elected officials that we
don't want them to come up with any
ideas or any money to fill that pit with
affordable housing. So, by getting rid
of this uh budget request, we're just
saying, "Oh, forget about it. I think we
should keep it."
Gabe,
>> the other thing I want to point out is
that there's a narrative that goes with
every goes along with the budget request
and the top need for the housing
committee is still affordable housing
and it has all of the information in
there. It's just not a budget request
because we don't have anything specific
for fiscal year 27.
Um, Gabe,
>> you stole my rebuttal.
That was what I was going to say. We we
are quite explicit in the need for
affordable housing in the in the
statement of district needs.
>> Alec,
>> to piggy back off of Marty's point, this
is also an endorsement to the city that
this is something that we need and it's
something that we support. Um, it's not
just a budget request. that also can
double as the statement of needs and
reinforce, especially as we're going to
see some new elected officials take
office next year, that this is something
that we wanted and continue to want
going forward.
>> Jim Jim and
>> I've been in
>> I've been in favor for greater
specificity in all of these budget
requests for as long as I can remember.
This particular one should speak to
demographics and and the amounts that
will be required to f to suit our
community district. That said, there's a
huge amount of money now that was passed
in the budget, I guess two years ago,
the state budget that was intended for
affordable housing. If we stop this
matter now,
I think officials will say, "Oh, they
don't need it. Let's reallocate it to
somewhere else." That's my view, just
how how somebody would likely interpret
it. Um, for that reason, I support the
uh I support the amendment
>> and be has her hand raised. Be please go
ahead.
>> Thank you. So you you have to look at
the responses that come into the capital
and what you don't want a response that
that we've been getting to this is yes
we support it but there's no specificity
unless you ask for specificity it's not
a budget request it's more of a need
statement so I don't support putting
something as generalized this that no
one could really respond to because
we're not giving details or data thank
you
>> um and I just want to make sure
everybody is reading the text that was
the request which does I think have some
spec specificity. So I know we're we're
speaking here about this as sort of a
very abstract idea but I do think there
are some pretty specific details listed
in the ask and sorry um who else would
like to speak
Tanya and then we'll we'd like to go
ahead and vote. Um, I was part of that
very brisk discussion in the budget. If
you watched the the film, you would have
seen it. Um, I also was one of the ones
that wanted to keep it as one of the
needs. But I think that this is a call
to arms to start really defining what
affordable housing is. And I think the
problem is that when we throw out
something as as broad as affordable
housing, we end up with all kinds of
poisoned pills being thrown back at us,
such as, "Okay, we'll give you
affordable housing, but here's a
casino." Well, yeah, we'll give you
affordable housing, but we're going to
take away all Uler or any other uh form
of community involvement because we
haven't been specific enough. And I
think it it's a call torren for us to be
far more specific and be fully educated
that affordable housing is not just you
know 15% of a building with rentals
there. Affordable housing takes on many
many different forms and we need to be a
little more serious about how we
approach it.
Um um Daniel and then we'll get back to
Mark.
>> I guess something that I'm a little
confused about and it's probably because
I'm new here is like really the drawback
of getting the response that says yes,
we support this. Thank you for putting
it in there. like I I feel like if
there's any risk at all of the
interpretation that Jim said, then it
would be dangerous to not include it.
And to the point that, you know, we're
opening up a door for like negative
repercussions by being too specific. I
feel like that's not like that's you can
read that and how they respond to it.
And if they respond to it by saying that
this is, you know, something they're on
board with and something that they want
to keep pushing and they're not sort of
responding it to by saying like they're,
you know, all these other externalities,
then that's not in there is how I kind
of see that. But, you know, I'm new here
still and so I don't really know like
maybe there is a specific drawback to
having that sort of bland response, but
I'm struggling to sort of see what it
is.
Marty, did you want to say something?
>> A little background on what the budget
requests do. Uh, granted, the responses
that we get are from the agencies, but
the elected officials use the budget,
the budget requests for what and where
they are going to work. that they may or
may not read what is going in our uh
other documentation, but they look
through the lines to see what is in the
budget request. When we finish here,
uh, our chair then will be going to the
burrow board in December where the
chairs of the 12,
um, community boards of Manhattan will
all be presenting to the Manhattan
Burough President what in fact they need
in their uh, communities.
Those issues which are indicated through
many of the many of the community boards
are the ones that the burrow board then
puts on their budget priorities.
If we don't want
if we don't say that we want something
uh we won't be included in whatever the
borrow board then is looking to present
money for it. So by putting out things
that have been there for a while that
some other committees, some other
community boards then fine is necessary.
That's well those are the kinds of
things that get funded and again it's
the elected officials more so than the
specific agencies that will be funding
these things. The specific agencies will
be doing more in regards to expense
budgets because those are items that are
50,000 or maybe 75 now. I mean uh up to
five years worth of use.
the electives and then above them the
state state electives are the ones will
who will be allocating the funds for
things like affordable housing. If we
don't want it we won't get it.
>> Um just and just in response to that I
think if you watched the video I I did
advocate that we keep this on the list.
Um, one of the things that the Burough
president was extremely proud of last
year was that every community board
listed affordable housing as their
number one need.
Um, so there is, as as Marty says,
there's there's something good about
working together across many boards. Um,
again, we don't I respect that the
committee voted on this, but um, I I
really do think it's important to have
this listed. So, um, Ann had her hand up
and then we have Be and Jim and then
we'll vote, please. We We've had a
pretty robust discussion.
>> Yeah. stuck a little bit on the
distinction between a district's needs
statements and the budget requests
and
the impact that has on the elected
officials because I completely agree
with what you said Marty that that the
the
agencies respond to what the electives
want um like well they it it is an
influence it's an important influence.
And so I just but but if we're
presenting it as a district need in some
ways that to me
overrides
if we don't have a really specific
request
then like isn't it more we're stating a
need than stating
um you know making making a
a specific request
>> and and I have to say too about things
dropping off. Sometimes things drop off
because the need is not as strong or the
issue has been resolved in other ways.
So it's not just that we dropped that.
>> Um and I might just in response to that
so far this is conjecture. We don't
really know what the what our elected
officials consider more important the
district needs or the or the budget
requests. Um maybe I meant to ask one
other thing. If if this
>> my other question, my actual question is
is if this goes on, does something have
to come off?
>> No.
>> And Jim, and then I'd like to go ahead
and vote. I think we've had quite a bit
of discussion.
>> Sandy, what are we voting on? Are we
voting on the
>> And I'm sweepy. We'll let you speak. You
had your hand up. Go ahead, Jim.
I would just like to to state that I
think there's little to no risk of
keeping things as they are going the
status quo and then next year because
none of this is going to be resolved by
then next year going ahead and doing a
thorough analysis of our housing needs.
what percentage of our population is
rent burdened, which can be determined
from the Department of City Planning
website and we can put that up and set
it up as a specific budget request and
unless somebody else is speaking about
that call question.
>> Uh B, did you want did you have
>> I had a process question. I assume what
was just said was an amendment to what
we have and therefore you need to vote
on the amendment before you vote on the
resolution. I was just pointing out the
process,
>> right? Yes. So the the vote is to amend
the resolution to include affordable
housing with the the text that was um
put on the screen. So
>> point of nation, what happened with the
ranking? Um we're we're proposing to
just put it as number one and
everything else goes down. There was a
discussion at the meeting that the
ranking isn't necessarily I let Steve
explain that
>> I mean each a it depends on who's
looking at it right if it's an elected
official maybe they look at all the
rankings but each agency will get only
their list so if it's the only if it's
only one request for an agency doesn't
matter where it is in the prior list
>> so we will have a roll call vote um and
>> yes will be in putting affordable
housing as handle one
>> at number one.
>> All right. So, as as was mentioned, we
are now about to conduct a roll call
vote to determine whether the resolution
on our budget requests will be amended
to include as the number one capital
request more affordable housing. Um, I
will call your name. You will say
whether you are in favor or whether you
are opposed. If you are in favor, you
want the resolution amended to include
affordable housing. Number one, capital
request. If you are opposed, we want the
resolution to stay exactly as it is. Is
that clear?
>> Yeah.
>> We'll move on.
>> All right. Tanya Arz
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Kyle Thad,
I do not think is here.
Neil Barkley,
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Marty Barrett,
>> Thank you. Elby Barroso,
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Daniel Bernstein
>> Thank you. Liz Burr
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Jim Collins.
>> Hi.
>> Thank you. Stu Desesser
>> favor.
>> Thank you. B Disman
>> abstain.
>> Uh
>> we didn't give you that as an option.
>> On a procedural matter.
>> On a procedural matter has to be one or
the other. So
>> nay.
>> Nay. Okay.
>> Uh Maya Donahghue is not here. Robert
Farfan
>> has not arrived.
>> Uh Barack Freriedman
>> in favor.
>> Okay. Jason Fromitz
>> Okay. Eric Goldberg
did not arrive yet. Okay. Justin
Goldberg.
>> All right. Gloria Hage.
>> Thank you. Ravia
>> in favor.
>> Okay, thank you. Paige Judge
>> Okay. Lupal Kakad is not here. John
Keller
>> in favor.
>> Okay. Uh Kate Kennedy.
Okay. Katie Lando
>> in favor.
>> Okay. Thank you. Uh Sandre Liftoff
Okay, Anton Melner is not here.
Sandy McKe
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Alec Militec
>> Thank you. Rich Mintz
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Kevin O'Keefe
>> Thank you. Rashma Patel
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Steven Perez.
>> Okay.
>> Will Perry in favor.
>> Thank you.
Omar Keshi
>> in favor.
>> Thank you.
>> Marryiam Ralph
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Michael Anroe is not here.
Larry Shy
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. An Seligman
>> Thank you. Sandro Sherrod is not here. I
think Wuin Sadiki
>> in favor.
>> Thank you. Alleti Simon is not here.
Mark Thompson
>> in favor.
Thank you, Gabe Tzo.
>> In favor.
>> Thank you, Cat Valero.
>> Thank you.
Uh, James Vera,
>> in favor.
>> Thank you, Jerry Weinstein.
>> In favor.
>> Thank you, Sarah Whittington.
>> Opposed.
>> Thank you. David Woods
>> in favor.
>> Thank you.
up.
>> All right. Um
33 people voting in favor
which leaves six voting uh opposed.
This is added to the resolution. So now
the resolution will indicate that public
uh that more affordable housing is the
number one capital request for this
board and all the other capital requests
will just shift down one spot.
>> So now we can vote on the final
resolution if there unless there are any
other issues that people would like to
discuss.
Okay, please go ahead and mark your
ballot. And Steve, did you have a report
you wanted to
>> just to remind all the committees to uh
we have to submit our updated need
statements also with the budget request.
So if you would like to make any changes
to your need statement, please do so uh
before the end of the month so that our
office can submit the report. Thank you.
>> And yes, please take a look at that
because there's some really outdated
information.
We talk about the pandemic.
It's passed.
>> The 1918 pandemic.
>> Spanish flu. Yeah. Um, okay. So, um,
next we have business affairs and
licensing and Seligman, vice chair, is
going to lead the discussion.
>> Back here.
>> Yeah. So uh yeah we have um
seven eight uh items on the agenda. Are
there eight resolutions? Are there does
anybody have any questions? Any
suggestions
perhaps to
>> bundle?
I think I think we can bundle I think
it's appropriate to bundle the ones that
are DOT
uh issues and ones that are um the state
liquor authority if we can do those into
kind of two trenches. Does that make
sense to everyone?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> So which ones are DOT?
>> So the first
>> A B C and D.
>> A B C and D. Yeah.
>> Okay.
makes in the bundle. Yeah. ABC second.
>> Okay. So, please go ahead and mark your
digital ballots for A, B, C, and D.
>> All right. And we're
>> and the the last four are all pretty,
you know, pretty straightforward, not
controversial.
Um,
SLA alterations or a couple of new
locations.
Um, so any questions or issues with any
of those?
>> Okay, seeing none,
>> motion.
>> Yeah,
>> I move.
>> Okay,
>> please go ahead and vote on E through H
and and do you have a report?
>> No, since I am not the chair, I will
wait the chair's report.
>> Okay, thank you. Um, moving on to land
use and waterfront. Gabe Tzo, chair.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. We have a resolution to augment
and make permanent installations of new
pedestrian amenity amenities including
seating and planters at 599 Lexington
Avenue. That's the plaza at 53rd with a
6B and M meet. It's uh it's lovely and I
urge you to support it. Any questions?
>> Okay. Um, seeing no um further
questions, we will vote on um 3A. Please
go ahead and mark your ballot.
>> Do you have a report?
>> Yes, I do. So, I'm uh sad to say I lied
to Brock last month. I said that the uh
the pinch point would be done by the end
of the decade. Uh DDC came to us saying
it would be done in Q3 of 2030. So, we
were close but not quite. We're going to
have a presentation uh next month from
the New York State Department of
Environmental Conservation. Maybe
>> we're working on it
>> uh to talk about the water supplies and
aquaer health. Um,
we are going to continue to the
discussion on the faith-based affordable
housing with answers to the questions
raised last month provided uh perhaps in
writing from Senator Gonzalez offices or
potentially we might have somebody from
uh Assembly Member Bores's office like
communicating with them. Um, and uh
that's it. Thank you.
>> Okay. Uh, transportation Jason from
chair.
>> Thank you. Uh so uh we have a resolution
tonight on uh uh uh quest for a
truckload lighting zone in front of 509
Thirdrd Avenue. It's at the corner of
34th Street and Third Avenue. Uh we had
a presentation from the um management
company andor owner of the space. Um and
they um the space is currently vacant.
They're retail space. uh they are
attempting to uh they desire to lease
the space to a grocery store. Uh they
have a fairly large basement space as a
part of uh the space that they're
looking at and they think that'd be
appropriate for a grocery store. Um they
they have they in their presentation to
us they shared that they were having
difficulty leasing the space given the
absence of a loading zone and that they
feel they would be able to more likely
secure space for a grocery store secure
a tenant for a grocery store if they had
a loading zone in place. Uh so we
ultimately reached the conclusion that
uh we felt it'd be appropriate to uh
write a resolution, pass a resolution in
favor of a loading zone being
established uh in front of that
storefront uh on the condition that the
space is leased to a grocery store. Uh a
couple other notes on the space um right
now. So it's about the length of a maybe
two cars tops. Uh currently, uh that
space is um a no parking or no standing.
No standing, I believe. Uh no stand no
standing from 7:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m. So
the truck loading zone would apply uh in
the evening hours. So the the 7:00 p.m.
to 7 a.m. in in those two spaces would
be um the become a truckloading zone.
Also important to note uh that it
wouldn't be exclusive to um to to the
landlord or to that store. Uh it would
be a truckloading zone that that could
theoretically be utilized by by anyone
although it would in fact be in front of
that store room. Um and uh again happy
to take any question.
>> Uh Tanya was first here.
Jason, can they specifically say that
there's a specific um couple of
supermarkets that have decided not to
lease it because of the loading zone or
is this just theoretical?
They they they
didn't really want to commit to like
naming anyone and they did, but
basically they were saying that they've
in touch with a lot of different tenants
uh and that that's a prevailing concern
from the grocery store tenants that
there's no loading zone and it makes
them hesitant to consider locating
there. Um, so I I think that's we
reached a reasonable compromise in uh
supporting this under the condition that
they're able to find at the grocery
store. Um, also I should have added um
that some the resolution makes the case
that uh a grocery store is valuable to
the community, provides access to fresh
food and jobs, and uh that we believe
it'd be valuable to have a grocery store
in that space.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> And then cat.
um
conditional on the grocery store but
regardless um was it discussed at the
meeting and apologies I didn't watch the
recording about adaptation because that
is a big corner lot um if there's trash
or recycling when you're talking about
loading just looking at the the grocery
store a couple blocks down the street
Trader Joe's is a great example there's
just a lot of coming and going of using
this in in favor. I think being a really
good mechanism whether the next tenant
whoever it is was that discussed because
that's a very high populated traffic
oriented area whether it's 7:00 p.m. to
7 a.m. It's also a high-rise residence
area. So I'm just curious was that
discussed at any night?
>> Uh it wasn't. I I think it's sort of out
of the scope of our purview as
transportation committee. Um but yeah, I
appreciate the concern, but yeah, not
something that that we discussed during
the committee. So,
>> okay, if there's no more discussion,
let's vote on um resolution 4A.
>> And while you were voting, I have a
brief report. Um
I attended DT's uh meeting with the
Margel Neighborhood Association on 34th
Streetway. Uh thanks for DT for putting
that together. uh they did a nice job of
uh responding and addressing concerns uh
that were raised there. Um and on a
similar note, uh DT has announced that
they either have or will be starting
implementation of the 31st Street
busway. Uh they expect that to be
completed uh before the end of the fall.
Uh and they have also shared that they
plan to begin uh installation of the
bike lane on 30 I'm sorry third third
Avenue the protected bike on third
Avenue uh starting this month and ending
this fall.
>> Great.
>> Yeah. Um what's what do you mean by the
end of the fall? Like by de November
December?
>> Yeah.
Uh I'm not exactly sure. I don't think I
can be specific.
>> Okay. Uh, all right. Next. Park,
landmarks, and cultural prayers. Neil
Barkley. Kevin.
>> Oh, I'm sorry, Kevin.
>> They did. They did come out with a
statement today that said December they
expect it to be ended.
>> Hello.
>> Good evening. Okay. Do we have one
resolution this evening?
[Music]
>> All right. This is for it's a resolution
regarding certificate of appropriateness
for LPC 257749
for exterior signage at 126 128 East 36
Street LPC being um landmark
preservation commission
and everyone had a vote right
question or it's okay
>> okay please go ahead and mark your
ballot
week
>> and you can now hit submit once you have
voted.
>> Okay. Um let's see. We discussed the
park that will be placed where the
former NYU parking lot was. Sandy
already gave pretty good description of
that. Uh Rafia, she returned to the
committee. She had a baby and so she
attended the baby also attended. So
>> you love babies.
>> All the good news we can get.
>> I know.
>> And then one thing I would just say I'm
pretty much unfinished, but uh was Steve
with the email that Steve sent out over
the summer. It was very detailed. it
pointed out a lot of things that you
know we didn't even think about with
different issues in the parks and budget
requests. So I just wanted to recognize
your work.
>> Well, sorry, Jim has a question for you.
>> Yes. Um,
I've noticed that Stson Park, uh, which
is supposed to be open from 6:00 a.m.
on, is very often not open at 6:00 a.m.
The gates are still closed. Just wanted
to bring that to your attention. I'm
usually up at 5:00 a.m. and walk by
there between 6:00 and 6:30.
>> Okay. We can um we can certainly let
parks know because on the other side
we're hearing that it's not closed, but
now it's not open. So maybe sometime
>> Yeah, that's what some of the complaints
are. But
>> yeah, we can certainly ask the parks
department about that.
>> Um
okay, next we have health and
environment. Gloria Hay is vice chair.
>> Hello.
>> A quick war to help Ruple. So Sandy
Ruple H6 and I to Belleview with Karen
Moore the chair of the Belg cab and Sage
Robinson the public affairs department
head on September 12th. So Rupa will
give more detailed about what happened
in that meeting, but overall
>> swag was really quite amazing.
>> Swag from the meeting.
>> Swag
swag. Um the the commitment, the
expertise, the innovative health care
and the dedication to serving all
including our community, the greater New
York City community and heads of state
was incredibly impressive. I had no idea
that they were the hospital for the
general assembly, but they are and they
have treated heads of state. So, also
just a couple things. They have 90
specialty clinics and they are the only
level one trauma center and level two
pediatric trauma center south of 68th
Street. So, working with them and
supporting them and their ability to
best serve our community is an important
priority. Tomorrow night, great meeting.
Come
We will be and we've heard about it
today. The beheard we're going to have a
presentation by a representative from
the mayor's office on the be her heard
program which is the behavioral health
emergency assistance response division.
And the program was launched in 2021.
Aims to have EMTs, paramedics from the
New York City Fire Department and mental
health professionals from the New York
City Health and Hospitals respond to 911
mental health calls instead of the NYPD.
And the program's aim is to treat mental
health emergencies as a health emergency
and not a public safety emergency. So,
we're going to get hear a lot about
what's been going on with that. Also,
tomorrow we have a discussion about
CRAM. K R A T O M which was brought to
our attention by a concerned member of
the community. It's a tropical evergreen
plant native to Southeast Asia and it
has been used as herbal medicine for you
know historically but it in high doses
it's addictive and basically it's sold
in stores in our community without any
warnings about possible addiction and as
of now is legal in New York state but
New York state legislation currently has
10 bills related to it so we're going to
be talking about that as well. Thank
you. Great.
>> That was too long.
>> Any questions? All right, let's move on
to housing and homelessness. Alec Milit.
>> Uh, so we are not meeting this month
because we know scheduled meeting with
Dewali. So we will be meeting in
November. Um last month I sort of
informally pulled community uh committee
members um for topics and issues that
we'd like to discuss uh this fall
regularly. So some of the issues that we
we show a lot of interest in include
homelessness housing policy. We're going
to get some uh speakers to come and uh
and speak to the committee. Um trying to
make uh a homeless organization come in
November and maybe even some housing
policy um organizations come in
December, January. So, uh stay tuned.
Thanks.
>> Hey, question.
>> Oh, question. I'm sorry, Brock.
Hey, so um we have a Midtown South
reszoning
like Fifth Avenue to 8th Avenue. Well,
it doesn't really include our area. We
have quite a bit of office buildings and
some of them could be converted. I think
just the first office buildings now
being converted into housing and like
120 studios or something like that. Um
have you taken up the issue of zoning um
and conversion? Um
>> we we haven't. That's more of a land use
committee issue, but as as I'm sure
everybody's aware, housing and land use
kind of go hand in hand. So, I think
this is probably something that maybe we
can talk about in the future. And
actually we do um as part of the ULERP
we have a a study being done by city
planning and that's one of the issues of
you know how do we directly get
affordable housing in our district and
um looking at spaces that they've asked
us to propose spaces that could be
utilized
>> but I also don't think the geography of
that resoning includes any portion of
our community.
>> No I do not.
Thank you.
>> Okay. Um, youth and education Katie
Katie Lando.
>> We haven't the youth and education
committee as yet this year. Our first
meeting is going to be this month on the
28th and we'll be talking about the the
um issues that we want to deal with this
year.
>> Any questions for you? Okay. Uh, public
safety and sanitation,
Stu Desert.
>> Oh, I'm sorry, Jim.
>> I saw a statistic. This scared me to
death. is that it said that the um one
of the national educational
outfits that assess the statistics
said that in New York City
fourth graders
only 19% were reading at grade level.
19%.
That may
be something you may want to look into.
I I'll dig up the article and send it to
you if you want us through the office.
But please, it's I don't know if they
need to get up on it or what, but it's
horrible.
You can't go teach a kid.
>> Yeah.
>> If you can't read.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I know there there's a the
schools have had been asked to implement
a new uh leaving teaching program and I
did talk to one principal about it who
said she asked the the teachers to have
the students on their desk but not to
use it because she feels it's so bad. So
I think there are real problems with
that. But thank you. I'd like to see
that.
Okay, Steu,
>> we're going to be talking about some
legislation proposed in Albany that
would expand the court court's
opportunity to send people who are
arrested to treatment as opposed to
Rikers. The premise basically being that
if somebody's
um in distress uh when they go into
Rikers, they're not going to come out of
um treatment tends to reduce recidivism.
Uh so we're looking about legislation
and surroundation.
>> Okay. Um, our elections committee,
Miriam Ruff.
>> Hi everyone.
The CD6 elections committee met
electronically on September 26, 2025 by
way of Zoom. Nominations were received
and the chair of the elections committee
communicated with all candidates
confirming their desire to hold office.
The meeting was held in accordance with
article 3 sections A and B of the CB6
bylaws. The elections committee reports
the following nominees. Chair Sandy
McKe, first vice chair John Keller,
second vice chair Justin Goldberg,
Treasurer Tanya Aras, assistant
treasurer no one yet. Secretary Jerry
Weinstein and Assistant Secretary, no
one yet. At this school board meeting,
members of the board may offer
additional nominees from the floor,
including themselves, but not including
members of the elections committee, and
that um elections committee is me, Maya,
and Omar. All nominees from the floor
must confirm their acceptance of the
nomination in person or immediately in
writing. No nominations will be accepted
after this opportunity given right now.
The election will take place at the
November full board meeting.
>> Yes, Cat. I would like to selfnominate
myself for assistant.
[Laughter]
>> One question. If elected, are you able
to assume the role and responsibilities
of the office you're running for?
>> Yes.
>> Great.
Anyone else?
Okay. Is there any old or new business?
>> All right. Seeing seeing none, um Justin
will now conduct the second roll call.
Members, I will now call on you for the
second roll call. If you've not
submitted your ballot, please do so now.
If you're unable to use the digital
ballot, CB6 staff will ask you for your
vote on each of tonight's resolutions.
>> Tanya Aras
>> present.
>> Kyle Tide
>> not here. Neil Neil Barlay,
>> Marty Barrett,
>> Elby Barroso,
Daniel Bernstein,
>> present.
>> Liz Burr,
>> Jim Collins,
>> here.
>> Stuart Stewart Desert
>> Uh, Beatrice Disman,
>> present.
>> Maya Donahghue,
>> not here.
>> Robert Fairfan,
>> Barack Freriedman,
>> present. Jason,
Eric Goldberg
here,
>> Justin Goldberg here,
>> Lauria Hage,
Rivia
>> present.
>> Page Judge
>> Rupaul COD
>> not here.
>> John Keller
>> here. Present.
>> Kate Kennedy.
>> Katie Lza.
Sandre Leftoff
>> present.
>> Anton Malner
>> not here.
>> Sandra McKe
>> present.
>> Alec Militic
>> Richard Vince.
>> Kevin O'Keefe.
>> Rashma Patel.
Steven Perez.
Will Perry
Meshi
>> present
May Ralph
Michael
>> Enro.
>> Lawrence Shers
>> present.
>> Ann Seligman.
>> Sandra Sherro
>> not here.
>> Mubin Sadiki.
>> Letty Simon
>> not here. Excuse
>> Mark Thompson here.
Gabriel Terso,
Pat Valero
>> here,
>> James Vero,
>> Jerry Weinstein
>> Sarah Whittington
>> present.
>> David Woods
>> here.
>> Present. Sorry.
>> Shu Yazo.
All right, let's quickly go through the
results. Uh the budget resolution on the
budget requests passed. 38 in favor, one
abstension.
Um all of the bulk resolutions passed
unanimously or nearly. You can read the
precise details in next month's minutes.
The land use resolution passed
unanimously. 39 in favor. Transportation
reszo passed 34 in favor, three opposed,
two abstensions, and the parks
resolution passed. 38 in favor, one
abstension.
>> Back to you, Sandy.
>> Okay. If there are no objections, we
will adjourn the meeting. Seeing no
further business, the meeting is
adjourned at 8:35.